друзі поговоримо про зовнішню політику
мовою кіно Ну щоб так було зрозуміліше
нашому президенту це біда коли актор
головний актор вирішує стати одночасно і
сценаристом і режисером і продюсером
фільму саме це сьогодні відбувається в
нас Зеленський вирішив що дипломатія має
стати моноспектаклем Ну добре спектаклем
надвох ще з Андрієм юрмаком результат
проблеми з ключовим союзником
сполученими штатами Америки в конгресі
США один з конгресменів поставив правку
щоб зупинити всю військову підтримку
України звичайно Ця пропозиція не
пройшла але знаєте скільки вони набрали
голосів 93 конгресмени проголосували за
93 конгресмени це майже половина всіх
республіканців які складають більшість в
конгресі США друзі це не дзвіночок це
колокал який дзвінить треба припиняти це
кіно в якому головний актор і режисер і
сценарист і продюсер бо таке кіно
провалюється